uncertain and unsteady on their feet
they are put onto buses and taken away
to russian occupied ukraine
many of the evacuees have been living
underground in the as of star steel
works for days on end
and creating this un humanitarian
corridor to get them out has been
fraught with danger
for the first time in all the days of
the war this vital green corridor has
started working there were two days of
ceasefire for the first time in the azov
style area more than 100 civilians have
already been evacuated women and
children fleeing hostilities right there
right on the as of style plans
for the families it is a harrowing
weight
marina's husband a fighter is still
trapped inside
she last spoke to him two days ago but
fears the russians won't allow the
soldiers to leave with
[Music]
inside the conditions are terrible
[Music]
as many as a thousand civilians and two
thousand fighters could be trapped here
in the network of tunnels and bunkers
above them air strikes and shelling have
been constant
getting in or out is almost impossible
and they are running out of supplies
these satellite images show how much of
this soviet era plant has been destroyed
whole areas of the complex have been
obliterated
in this video posted on social media by
the azov regiment
a medic describes how they are
struggling
with
there are hundreds of injured fighters
down here unable to get the medical
treatment they need
so far in these evacuations only a small
number of people have managed to get out
there are hopes more will escape in the
coming days
but as conditions worsen it's clear it
needs to happen soon
alex rossi sky news denite pro